Welcome to deep reinforcement learning
or CS 224R.
Uh
uh really excited to be teaching it
again this quarter. My name is Chelsea.
I am the instructor of the course. I'm
an assistant professor here at Stanford.
I do research on
uh reinforcement learning, robotics, and
language models and a variety of other
topics. So, the plan for today. So,
we're going to be covering uh the course
goals and some logistics. Hopefully,
this will be fairly short uh cuz all
this information is available online. Uh
after that, we'll be talking about why
study deep reinforcement learning and
actually get into some technical content
on modeling behavior and reinforcement
learning.
Um the key learning goals for today is
what even is deep reinforcement
learning? Uh how do we go about actually
representing behavior in a way that we
can optimize behavior? And how do we
formulate a reinforcement learning
problem?
So, what do we mean by deep
reinforcement learning? So, uh first for
reinforcement learning, we mean
decision-making problems.
And these are problems where a system
needs to make multiple decisions based
on a stream of information. So, it'll
observe and then take an action based on
that observation and then observe again
and take another action.
And we'll be studying those kinds of
problems as well as the solutions to
those kinds of problems. And that
includes things like imitation learning,
model-free and model-based reinforcement
learning, offline and online
reinforcement learning, multitask and
meta reinforcement learning, as well as
uh a little bit of a um extra focus on
reinforcement learning for large
language models, and reinforcement
learning for robots.
Um so, that's kind of the crux of the
reinforcement learning aspect of the
course. And we'll be emphasizing
solutions that scale to deep neural
networks and we'll be spending a lot
less time on solutions that don't
pertain to deep neural networks.
Now, how does deep RL differ from other
machine learning topics? So,
um
hopefully, a lot of you have some
experience with machine learning. And
often times in machine learning, you'll
have uh some kind of input-output pair,
XY, and you'll have a bunch of these
in some data set. And then your goal is
to learn something that can map from X
to Y.
Uh and another thing is that we kind of
typically assume in these data sets is
that these data points are sampled from
some distribution and are sampled um I
in an
independent and identical uh way from
that distribution.
Uh and this is actually where
reinforcement learning differs quite a
bit. So, in supervised learning, we have
labeled data, we learn this function,
we're directly told what to output,
we're kind of told what the answer is
uh that for that given input.
And the inputs are our IID samples.
Now, uh in reinforcement learning, the
picture is a little bit different. So,
ultimately, our goal is to learn
behavior.
Uh and we'll actually use different uh
kind of notations to refer to inputs and
outputs. So, specifically, our goal will
be to map
uh from
states to actions. And we'll refer to
the function that we do that mapping as
pi.
And
unlike in supervised learning, we're not
going to be directly told what the
answer is.
Our goal will actually be to learn this
behavior from much more indirect
feedback.
And so, in reinforcement learning, the
goal is to learn this behavior
uh pi of A given S.
And this will be from experience. Uh and
actually, experience often drawn from
the policy that you're learning or the
this function that you're learning.
And the data is not going to be sampled
from a single distribution. It's
actually going to be sampled uh in a way
that actually depends on the policy or
or the function that you're currently
learning.
Um so, these are the two big
differences. And what I mean by behavior
is this could include motor control like
controlling a robot. It could include a
chatbot that is interacting with a
person.
It could be playing a game. It could be
driving a car. It could be an agent
that's interacting with the web
and a wide range of other domains.
So that's how reinforcement learning
differs from typical machine learning.
We don't have the ability to cover
everything in deep reinforcement
learning. And so we're going to try to
focus on the core concept behind deep
reinforcement learning methods so that
you can then use those core concepts to
understand more advanced methods should
you choose to dive deeper into the
topic.
We'll also focus on implementation of
algorithms to get to the point where you
feel comfortable implementing algorithms
yourself.
And we'll give examples in robotics,
control, and language models
especially in lecture and in projects,
but a lot of the techniques will
generalize more broadly.
And also just to focus on topics that we
think are the most useful and the most
exciting to cover.
If you're interested in more theory and
other applications that are kind of
beyond some of these, CS 234 can also be
an excellent one.
Yeah, and then the core goal is really
to be able to understand and implement
existing and emerging methods in deep
reinforcement learning.
Cool. So why study deep reinforcement
learning?
Um
I'll list out a number of things here
and then we'll dive into each one a
little bit more.
So one we already talked about is going
beyond supervised example.
And there's a lot of scenarios where AI
model predictions have consequences.
Uh And if we want to take into account
those consequences, then we need a
framework for thinking about those
consequences and how to optimize the
behavior with respect to those
consequences.
So for example, if you like listen to
music on Spotify for example and the
Spotify algorithm is recommending a song
for you to play,
that recommendation uh or even actually
just playing it directly for you, that
recommendation has consequences such
that the next time it recommends a song,
it probably shouldn't recommend the same
song or and it may want to also stay
within the same genre and so forth. And
so if we want to think about developing
AI systems that can take into account
those consequences, that's what deep
reinforcement learning allows us to do.
Um there's also scenarios where direct
supervision isn't available. Uh so for
example, if you have uh a coding
assistant like uh like Cursor or
Co-pilot, and you want to give it
feedback uh saying like that was a great
uh they did a great job there or did a
poor job there, um that supervision is
not the output. Uh it's a more indirect
supervision. Uh and that kind of
learning from that sort of indirect uh
supervision or really any sort of
objective um can be formulated as a
reinforcement learning problem. So it's
a lot more flexible than supervised
learning.
Um reinforcement learning is also widely
used and deployed in a number of
performant AI systems.
Um
also learning from experience in my
opinion seems kind of fundamental to
intelligence. And so just from a kind of
a philosophical level in terms of
building intelligent machines, uh
figuring out how to actually develop
algorithms that can learn from their own
experience uh seems pretty fundamental
to that. And it's fundamental to be able
to actually make discoveries of new
things rather than just mimicking the
data.
And then lastly, there's also some
pretty exciting uh open research
problems as well and so it makes it a
pretty exciting area to do research on.
Um and then lastly, I I was also
actually uh last weekend I was telling a
friend that I was making slides on why
study deep reinforcement learning um and
how I was I was making several slides on
it.
And they were like, "Well, why do you uh
this this question doesn't seem very
hard. Uh the answer is just $1 million
in in total compensation from OpenAI."
Uh so maybe if you're not motivated by
one through four, uh, this can be some
motivation.
Okay.
Um,
so diving into the beyond supervised
learning,
uh, decision-making problems are
everywhere and can't be directly
formulated as supervised learning. Any
sort of AI agent is captured by this.
Uh, also if you want your AI system to
interact with people, like chatbots or
recommenders, um, or scenarios where it
will affect decisions will affect future
outcomes or observations, these kind of
feedback loops, um, these are
reinforcement learning problems.
Um, and then yeah, like I mentioned
before, if your labels if you don't have
labels and your objective isn't just
accuracy or it's non-differentiable, um,
these are scenarios where reinforcement
learning is useful.
Um, now I mentioned it that deep RL is
used in a variety of different
performance systems. What am I talking
about there?
Two examples of legged robots that have
learned behavior with reinforcement
learning. Uh, in this case reinforcement
learning in simulation and then
transferred to the real world. Uh, so
you can get some cool stuff like uh,
puppy robots and dancing humanoids. Uh,
and these are actually like real robots
in the real world, uh, policies that are
are were trained with deep reinforcement
learning.
Uh, beyond legged robots, uh, and
dancing, you can also get robots that
can manipulate with arms to do tasks,
uh, using, uh, in this case imitation
learning, uh, but so within the scope of
this course. Uh, so the left is a robot
that is unloading laundry and folding
the laundry. On the right is a robot
that can fold, uh,
some simple origami. Uh, so some pretty
cool stuff you can do with, um,
with these kinds of methods.
Um, you can also learn to play complex
games. So,
uh, several years ago
DeepMind used deep reinforcement
learning to train a system to play the
game of Go
and it actually defeated the, um, the
champion of Go, uh, defeated Lee Sedol,
uh, which was really impressive in its
own right. And another really cool thing
about it was kind of coming back to this
discovery town of AI systems, uh, there
was this move that surprised everyone
that was an expert in Go. Uh, it's
called move 37, uh, and it kind of
discovered a strategy that humans
previously hadn't thought of before. Uh,
so this is an example of how
reinforcement learning can, uh, be a
tool to discover new solutions. And this
might be useful beyond games, but if you
want to, for example, discover,
uh, cure diseases or discover, uh,
things that require experimentation, uh,
provides a tool for doing those kinds of
things.
Um, and there's not just robots and
games. So nearly all modern language
models use some form of RL for post
training.
Uh, especially for more advanced
reasoning as well.
Uh, there's also research on traffic
control using reinforcement learning and
finding ways to insert cars into, um,
into human-driven cars in order to
increase the throughput on different
roads.
Research on training generative models
with reinforcement learning. Uh, in this
case, for example, trying to make the
the generations adhere to a particular
prompt. So,
uh, what these are showing is on the
left, if you ask, uh, the base
generative model to make a picture of a
dolphin riding a bike, it'll give you
this, which is not a very good picture.
And then you can optimize it through
reinforcement learning to get a picture
that, uh, is actually following the
prompt more effectively. Um, and
likewise for other prompts as well.
Uh, and there's also these, um, is being
used for chip design. Uh,
this this is a paper that, uh,
uh, designed chips that are used in
Google's production TPU,
uh, which is also pretty useful. Uh,
yeah.
Great. Um, so those are a few examples.
There's a number of others that I didn't
cover as well.
Um,
the next thing that I mentioned in terms
of studying deep RLs, it kind of seems
somewhat fundamental to intelligence.
And for this, I want to tell a little
bit of a story,
uh which is that when I was starting my
PhD, uh
at right after I graduated undergrad, I
joined a lab that was uh looking at
reinforcement learning for robots.
And uh right next to where I was was
sitting was this robot here. And
oftentimes,
uh
there was a postdoc in the lab who was
running experiments with reinforcement
learning. And so, I would look over at
the robot, and it would be doing things
like this.
And the thing that really kind of
fascinated me about watching this robot
is you can actually see it learning uh
over time.
And at the beginning, it knew nothing
about how to, for example, insert and
kind of assemble these two parts of its
toy airplane. And at the end, it's
actually able to do it quite
performantly.
This is like really, really cool. You
can actually see it learning from its
own experience
in the real world.
Um so, essentially, reinforcement
learning enables this kind of ability to
get better with practice that isn't uh
present in other machine learning
systems.
Now, there's one caveat to this, which
was that this particular robot had its
eyes closed. It uh it wasn't using a
camera, essentially.
Uh and that seemed like a really
fundamental limitation to me. And so, uh
I actually kind of then worked with the
postdoc on a follow-up project uh with
vision, uh with with cameras, um and was
able to, in this case then, learn in the
real world how to insert the red block
into the shape sorting cube.
And again here,
with experience, it's able to get better
and better uh as it practices the task
over and over again.
And then after the learning process, uh
it's
So, it's still learning, still
improving. It ends up uh getting a
success rate, I think, around
95 or 100% success at the end.
Um and then I can hold the block out, uh
or at least a young version of me can
hold the block out for the robot. And uh
the robot can then put it up at the
right block into the sink for instance.
Now these are very simple tasks. Uh this
was uh
in some ways a long time ago uh and now
we have robots that can fold laundry and
and uh do dancing and so forth.
Um
but it's kind of one of the reasons why
I like showing these videos is they
really show the reinforcement learning
process in the real world and the
ability to improve with practice.
Um at the same time there's also a ton
of exciting research problems that are
open. Uh and so if you're someone who's
excited about doing research, um there's
challenges like how does uh this robot
learn to represent what is good for the
task?
Um or how does an agent generalize its
behavior not just to one scenario but to
many different scenarios and um can we
apply such a system at scale with large
diverse data sets and transfer from
other tasks and other goals?
Uh and can we use reinforcement learning
to learn long horizon tasks like cooking
a meal or solving a really hard math
problem?
Um or and can robots practice fully
autonomously? For this last point, I
showed you some videos of reinforcement
learning. That's not actually always
what it looks like. So sometimes if you
run reinforcement learning a robot, it
looks more like this where the robot is
trying to hit the hockey puck into the
goal. And
every time the robot attempts the task,
uh it then it kind of needs to start
over and re-attempt it. And the robot
doesn't actually know how to undo the
task. And this is my friend Yevgen. Um
you might notice that Yevgen is actually
doing more work than what the robot is
doing. Uh which doesn't kind of quite
seem like the right way uh of doing
things. It's not practical to collect a
lot of data this way.
Okay. So um
and along all these topics, these are uh
some of the topics that we'll be
covering in this course as well. So
we'll be talking about reward learning
and how to represent different rewards.
We talked about offline RL, multitask RL
and meta RL, hierarchy and reasoning,
um and reset free RL as well.
Cool. Um so any questions on why deep
is interesting to study.
Yeah, so in the the question was uh how
do you learn a reward when the robot is
learning in the real world? And in that
particular example, the
um
we represented the reward as the
distance between uh or the negative
distance between the kind of the
position of the object and the goal
position of the object. And uh you might
have noticed that in the case with the
shape-changing cube, the robot was
actually holding the cube. Uh and so
that could that meant that we could
actually measure using the robot arm
position where the cube was as well.
Um now you can't do this in practice in
many scenarios. Uh it's kind of specific
to that task. Uh and in the in the
hockey example, there there was actually
a a mocap marker on the hockey puck that
measured where it is in um yeah, where
it is in the room. Uh and in general,
it's very hard and that's why reward
learning uh is kind of necessary in
order to solve the problem in a more
general way.
Good question.
Okay. So, now let's dive into modeling
behavior and uh and reinforcement
learning.
So,
we need to figure out how to represent
experience as data. So, like as the
robot was practicing, we need to think
about how we can actually represent what
was captured in that video as data to
learn from. Uh and so uh
here's another example of a robot
learning in the real world. Um we might
also want to think about how to
represent
text from like a chatbot, for example.
We need to In in either of these cases,
we need to think about experience that
the agent collects. How do we actually
write that down as data?
So, the way that we do that um typically
in reinforcement learning is first we'll
think about the state of the world and
we'll use S to denote the current state
of the world.
Um
and
for example, in in the case of the
robot, the state of the world might be
uh like the position of the arm and the
position of the towel and the position
of the hook.
Or if you don't have access to
information about the towel directly, it
might just be an image captured from the
robot's camera and the position of the
joints of the arm if you have access to
that.
Now, you can't always
represent like you can't always have
access direct access to the state of the
world. And so
sometimes we'll use
we'll sometimes we'll refer to an
observation O
and use observations instead of states.
And the difference between observations
and states is that with observations, it
may not capture
all of the information you need to make
a decision. And you might actually need
to think about past observations that
you've seen before. So, for example, for
a chatbot,
if you're interacting with it, you can
think of the observation at a given time
step as the most recent message that you
sent to that chatbot.
And then that most recent message
doesn't tell the chatbot everything it
needs to know about what the next
response should be.
And so, what you need is you actually
need to give it the history of past
observations,
not just the current observations, in
order to make a decision.
I'm going to we'll talk a little bit
more about this state observation
distinction in a couple of slides.
So, this is kind of capturing what the
agent is observing. Now, we also need to
capture how it's taking actions, how
it's actually making decisions. And
we'll refer to those
decisions as actions.
And we'll use the the letter A to denote
actions.
And then
in terms of a given interaction with the
environment
we will think of that as a trajectory.
So, that will be a sequence of states
and actions or a sequence of
observations and actions.
This is kind of uh,
one way to represent
behavior and
this will then kind of results in a data
set of trajectories
rather than a data set of XY pairs.
And then we need to think about like
what is actually the goal of the task?
Um, and that's where reward functions
come in. And reward functions are
essentially telling us how good is a
given state and action.
Uh, in many cases the reward function
will only depend on the state.
Uh, and for example, it'll might tell
you how close is the towel to being hung
or is the towel hung or not. Um, or in
the case of a towel bot it might be like
how happy is the user uh, or did they
give me a thumbs up or a thumbs down.
And then this experience is um, is is
kind of the trajectory um, and that
trajectory might be augmented with the
rewards.
Uh, so this is kind of each time you uh,
kind of roll out the policy
uh, you'll get some sort of data in this
form.
Let's talk a little bit more about
states and observations first. So, um,
the way that we'll we can then think
about states and actions is
uh, it's always a lot like a Markov
chain.
So, we'll have
um, say we'll have the first
state of the world. This is for example,
in the robot case, let's say the towel
is on the table and there's a hook and
the goal is to put the towel on the
hook. Um, this first state is like the
robot in some neutral position and the
towel on the table.
And then the robot will
take some action.
This is like moving its arm to a
particular location.
And that action
and the current state will inform
what the next state is.
And then from there uh, the towel will
be maybe the towel's in the same
position if the robot was just moving in
free space or maybe the towel has moved.
Uh, and then the robot will then take
another action and it will move its arm
again.
And
the
state and actions will then inform the
next state.
Now, one crucial thing here is that
the
um, we kind of can think of how the
environment is changing under what's
called a dynamics function. So, you have
like P of S3 given S2
and A2.
This is kind of the dynamics of the
world. This is how does the arm actually
move in space and how does the towel
move in space as a function of where it
was before and what the robot did.
And the crucial thing to notice here is
that
S3 only depends on S2 and A2 and it
doesn't depend on F1.
And so,
like there's no S1 in this probability
distribution.
And essentially,
uh, S3
is going to be,
um,
independent of S1 if you condition on
S2.
And this sort of independence property
is
called the Markov property.
Uh, and it's, uh,
one of the things that actually ends up
being very useful in reinforcement
learning. So, it allows you to break up
the problem in, um, into these scenarios
where you don't have to worry about all
the dependencies that come before it.
Now, um, if you have observations
instead of states,
then things look a little bit different.
Uh, and the way that we can think about
observations is the observation is a
function
of the current state
and it may not contain all the
information that's in the state.
And so, um, the observation at any given
point in time, for completeness, we'll
draw each of them here.
And then if you don't have access, if
you can't observe the state,
that means now that O2, or sorry, O3, um
it's not just a function of O2 and A2,
it's actually also a function of O1 if
you cannot observe the state.
Cool. So, on the slides, we can think
about uh this model where we have these
dynamics. We don't know how the world is
going to evolve. We can't directly
observe like how the power We can't
predict the future.
Um
until these dynamics are unknown. And
these dynamics are independent of ST - 1
in this case, uh and that's known as the
Markov property.
Any questions on that?
Yeah, so the question is in practice,
how many past observations do we need to
infer the state? Uh it is heavily domain
dependent. Uh
the
uh in like uh yeah, heavily domain
independent. In a lot of robotics
examples, you can often get away with
just using like uh the current sensor
observations,
um but it depends a lot on like what the
sensors are. Like if you have tactile
sensors, for example, those are um often
times don't contain as much information
as like vision observation, for example.
And so, like how close you are to a
table, uh you you have no idea when
you're not making contact, and then once
you make contact, you know. So, that's a
lot more partially observable than um
than image, for example. Uh but then if
you have the images in addition to that,
then that gives you a more complete
representation.
Yeah, so why is the reward function a
function of both the state and the
action and not just the state? Um one
example of this is uh we can go back to
a robotics example. So, say that you are
a humanoid robot, and you're trying to
learn how to walk. Um and maybe like one
natural reward function is just how much
forward progress have you made? So,
where is your body? And that would be
kind of dependent on the state. Um one
scenario where you might want the action
is is that scenario where if you don't
want to be using too much energy uh,
because you uh, you don't want to be
like uh, tensing up all the motors, for
example, or I guess
tensing up muscles more like for
instance, but if you don't want to be
exerting too much pushing too much
energy into your motors, uh, then you'll
want to depend on the actions as well.
And you could basically have some
penalty on how much torque you're
putting through the motors.
Um, so that's one example. Uh, in many
cases you can just depend on the state,
uh, but um, there are some examples
where you don't you want to kind of
penalize taking too much action.
Yeah, so the question is um, if the
observation is only part of the state,
then why does um, why does kind of a
future observation not independent of
past observations? And um, the reason
for that is that the we actually go back
to the tactile example. So, say that you
are you make contact and then you stop
making contact and then you make contact
again.
Um,
the in that case the most immediate past
observation doesn't actually tell you
that much information about the current
state. Uh, and whereas this observation
actually tells you a lot more
information about the state. And so
the um, that O3,
uh, you actually can learn more about
you can actually figure out more about
O3 when you don't just condition on O2,
but also condition on O1.
Um, and there's also a way uh, for folks
familiar with graphical models to
actually um, think about if you kind of
marginalize out these variables, uh,
you'll actually see that in the
graphical model. Um, I don't want to go
into that today, uh,
but that's another way that you can see
that.
Correct. Yeah, yeah. So, yeah, if you
were to estimate and predict O3, then
you would want you would need to use all
of um, you you need to use past
observations, um, but the actual
observation uh, in this graphical model
is um, kind of dependent on the the
state which might be unobserved or
unknown.
Cool.
Um, so let's walk through a couple
examples of what this might look like.
So, uh in the robotics case
the state could give uh could include
three different things. One would be the
RGB images from any cameras on the
robot,
the positions of all the joints of the
robot, and the velocities of the joints.
Uh and so this is like kind of a fairly
common state representation for a robot
system.
And the like the images would be like
uh would be at actually different
dimensionality than the positions. And
so you might need actually configuring
your neural network in a way that can
accept those different dimensionalities.
The action would then be the commanded
next joint position. So, how are you
going to kind of move your joint? Are
your joints currently like at 90°? Maybe
you'll try to move it to 92°.
The trajectory then would be a sequence
of states and actions. So, a sequence of
videos or a sequence of of images, which
is essentially a video, a sequence of
joint positions, and a sequence of
commanded joint positions.
Now,
what does that sequence actually entail?
Uh typically what we do is we'll
discretize time,
and this sequence will then, for
example, be at 20 Hz. So, you'll your
video will be 20 frames per second, and
you'll have joint observations 20 times
per second, and you'll also have
commanded actions 20 times per second.
Uh I always found this a little bit
unintuitive when I first learned it
because as a person I'm I don't really
think about like I'm making a decision
20 times every second,
uh but it is oftentimes the most
practical way to uh
represent data and behavior on like
physical systems like robots.
Uh and then for the reward function
there's a few things you could use here.
One could be one if the towel is on the
hook
uh in in state S and zero otherwise. You
could also have some sort of penalty on
on like the torques that you're applying
on the action and something like that.
So, that's a robot example. Now, let's
go to like a chatbot example. So, here's
the observation. We We would likely
wouldn't have like a compact state
representation, and so we be using
observations. And the observation could
be the user's most recent message.
The action would be the chatbot's next
message. So, this would be potentially a
sentence or a paragraph. It could
potentially be very large.
And then, you can think of the
trajectory as the conversation trace.
So, like the kind of history of the
current conversations.
And unlike in the robotics example,
this won't necessarily be at like a
fixed like 20 Hz frequency.
Uh it might take longer for a user to
respond or something like that. And so,
this is an example of how trajectories
might vary in terms of how time is
represented. So, in the first case, time
is represented as a 20th of a second.
Whereas in the second case, time is
represented as when the user responds
next.
Um and then there's an example reward.
Maybe it's one if the user gives an
upvote, -10 if the user gives a
downvote, uh and zero if there's no user
feedback.
Okay. So, here's an example. These are
examples of how we can set up
reinforcement learning. Now, I would
like to ask you to formulate
uh a reinforcement learning problem.
And in particular,
uh
I'd like you to define the state or
observation, the action, trajectory, and
reward for either one of these three
examples, or choose your own example.
Yeah, so in this example,
um
the
there's a question of Basically, the
question is like, why would this be an
observation versus a state? Um it could
actually be formulated both ways,
potentially.
Uh the It It kind of depends on the
details of the sensor measurements. So,
um
as one example, if your sensors are just
looking at like current like a LiDAR of
like the current depth around you, and
like a picture of what's in front of
you,
um
yeah, maybe something along those lines.
Uh one thing that that would be missing
is like how fast the cars are moving
around you,
uh like the velocity of the cars, and
that um that's probably quite important
for
uh like what's going to happen in the
future. Uh like if it's stopped versus
moving at 60 mph. Um
now you could potentially try to include
uh a history of like lidar information
to get that velocity information, and
then represent your state as like a
three kind of a 3-second history or so
for example. Um and this will kind of
represent a theme, which is that
typically to represent uh to handle
observations, we'll use a little bit of
history and then that can form your
state representation. Um so it's a
little bit ambiguous in this particular
case, and yeah, it comes down to the
details. Yeah.
Yeah, so the question is in the robot
example, if the reward is one if it's on
the
on the hook and zero otherwise, how do
you actually learn cuz you if you're
just like if you don't actually ever do
that at any point, then you'll have very
little supervision signal. You'll just
have zero reward all the time.
Uh and so in that actually in that
particular video, we initialized um we
actually showed the robot how to do it
uh a couple times as initialization, and
that helped uh
helped it with what we'll call
exploration. Um and if you have very
sparse rewards, rewards that have very
uh little signal and are not kind of
nicely shaped towards the goal, then
usually that that kind of data might be
important for uh for jump-starting the
reinforcement learning process.
Cool. Cool. Yeah, so um if folks can
hear that, the you'd have the state
being um something like the HTML and
like the URL, like information about the
web page, uh and where you're at. The
action would be interacting with it, uh
and the reward would be like whether or
not some task is completed.
Yeah, so the question is is basically
everything an observation because
sensors are like may not be perfect.
So, you could always choose to model
something as an observation if you're
worried about like sensor noise or
something like that.
There are large It's always potentially
like large downsides to it if you need
to add a lot of history.
The And so, sometimes we will kind of
approximately
approximate something as a state even if
it might be lacking information like
maybe
I don't know once every like 10,000
times the sensor fails and gives you
like a black image or something like
that.
Even though that would technically be
like an observation case, you might
still use it as a state representation
because of how it affects the algorithm.
Yeah, so if I understood correctly,
you're asking for observations it could
either be like everything currently or
could be a delta from the previous
observation.
Yeah, and the Yeah, it would come out
down to different trade-offs often
times.
If you are going to be including a lot
of history, then kind of compressing it
by using deltas
could potentially make a lot of sense,
but it Once we get into policies,
maybe it'll also become more clear.
Okay, so now that we've talked about
formulating the reinforcement learning
problem, let's talk about actually
representing behavior. So, we want to
map typically from states or
observations to action. And we will To
do that, we'll use what's called a
policy.
And this policy will often use pi to
denote a policy or basically use pi.
And this can just be a neural network.
In this case, it's a convolutional
neural network. It could be a
transformer. It could be like a simple
fully connected neural network. It could
be a linear function. And this is going
to be mapping from the states or
observations or the sequence of
observations to actions.
We'll use typically theta to refer to
the parameters of that neural network
that you're trying to learn.
And so then, when you're actually using
a policy to take actions, we'll then
observe a state,
uh take an action, uh and observe a next
state. And when we take actions, we're
actually going to be sampling from our
neural network.
Uh so we'll actually be running a
forward pass through the neural network
uh to select an action, and then execute
that action in the real world, and
observe the next state.
Um
cool.
Uh and so the result of this process is
a trajectory. And when we're using a
policy to generate this trajectory, we
often refer to it as a rollout or an
episode. Um you can think of it as like
kind of one episode of learn- one
episode of learning is like one attempt,
and then trying it again and again.
And
the I guess the terminology rollout is
in the sense that you're um you're kind
of sequentially uh
going policy dynamics policy dynamics,
and so you're kind of rolling out this
process to create a trajectory.
Um great. And then if you only have
observations and you don't have states,
the solution is to give your policy
memory. And so you can pass in multiple
observations, whereas if you only give
it a state, you actually don't have to
give it any memory, and you can just
give it as input state. Uh this is very
convenient because uh if you have a
large amount of um memory, it will take
up a lot of memory on your computer or
uh on your GPU.
Uh
but if you only have observations, then
you have uh in some ways no choice but
to provide that memory to the policy.
And for this, you may use like sequence
models, for example. In language models,
you're going to be using sequence models
that use the previous observations.
Yeah, so the question is is T like the
current time step, or is it uh kind of
general from the beginning to the end?
So, um this capital T I'm using to
denote kind of the end of the
trajectory, so the length, the number of
states and actions in a trajectory. Um
and then T I'm kind of referring to a
given time step, um and this uh and kind
of generalizing it so that you can think
about this is happening at all time
steps from t equals from lowercase t
equals 1 to lowercase t equals capital
T.
Is it ever useful to condition it on the
both the observation and the state? So,
in this case, um
the state has strictly more information
than the current observation and so
uh it isn't useful to add the
observation if the state is truly the
state that captures everything.
So, if we go back to this diagram, if we
um if we have states,
then we only need to provide the current
state. Whereas, if we have observations,
that's where adding histories is
helpful. So, it's it's a distinction
between states and observations.
Why is it having history of observation
helpful? Yeah.
Yeah, so it basically the past
observations will help give you more
information about what S1 is.
Uh and so, if you only have observations
and you don't know what the underlying
state of the world is. So, being as
another example in like language
modeling, um if you are having a
conversation with the user, um each
thing that the user says is a different
observation and the past observations
will actually tell you a lot about what
the current state of the world is. So,
if their first question was like, "Can
you write this piece of code to me?" and
then you maybe wrote some piece of code
and they give you some feedback, it's
actually very important to include the
all those past observations um to
actually capture the the full state of
the world.
I mean, that might not be true in all
cases. Uh
the but in in like yeah, many many cases
the previous observations uh will also
be useful for the current state.
Yeah, so you there also could be
scenarios where you might want a kind of
a two-stage process, one where you first
infer the state and then a second
process where you
um where you then predict the action
from that state. If you have some idea
for like a good representation for the
underlying state, then that sort of
information could be useful in trying to
model the underlying state. Um in other
cases
uh it's simplest just to go straight
from observation, sorry.
Okay.
Um
moving on a little bit. So,
we've talked about states, actions,
policies. What is actually the goal of
reinforcement learning?
Uh so, our goal is to maximize reward.
And so, if we have a trajectory,
um we don't want to just optimize for
like the reward at one time step, but we
want to optimize for having reward
across the entire trajectory.
Uh and so, we can represent this as
maximizing the sum of rewards.
Now, one thing that came up is that this
is actually not a deterministic
quantity.
So, if you have a policy,
um and you're then executing that policy
in the world,
the reward that you get isn't always
going to be the same every time you run
your policy.
Uh and so, a question for you, uh
why is this not a deterministic quantity
and what are the sources of variability
that might cause the sum of rewards to
differ
from one trajectory to another
trajectory?
Yeah, so one source of variability is
that the the state doesn't just depend
on the
the action and the state, but there's
also kind of randomness that can affect
the next state.
Other sources of variability, yeah?
Your policy may not be deterministic
either. So, there's kind of two really
key sources.
That's a good question. You might have a
stochastic reward function. So,
typically we actually model the reward.
This is a very interesting point. We
often typically model it as
deterministic, as a function.
Um
the and and kind of have the source of
randomness come from states and actions.
Now, um if you don't know the state,
then it could actually be viewed as
stochastic if you only have the
observations.
Right. So, if you're doing reward
learning, um
is there the question is is there
stochasticity there? Um typically you'll
still model it as a as a reward
function.
So, you might have some you might not
have full certainty of exactly what the
reward is.
Um
and perhaps you might want to leverage
that uncertainty into like in some ways
in the learning process.
Um
that's
maybe something to take offline. There's
some considerations there.
Yeah, so the other thing is your goals
might change over time.
And in that case, the reward function
will change. We'll actually often model
that as a different a whole different
decision process at that point if the
rewards change
rather than kind of having it being with
the within the same one.
Um
the
Yeah, there are scenarios where you
might want a non-stationary
decision process, I guess, but
um
and you can actually often put that
randomness into the state instead of
putting it in the reward function. Like
maybe there's some underlying goal that
you can't observe that's in the state.
Uh and then the reward function remains
deterministic.
Um and so Yeah, generally without losing
generality, you can push that into the
state if you need it.
Cool. So,
um
the two main sources of variability that
you have to worry about are the world is
stochastic. So, the environment is these
dynamics. This is this is a
distribution. It's not a deterministic
function.
And the second is that the policy is
also not
not deterministic. And so, in driving,
for example, other cars are going to
behave in ways that are random.
And your car might not make the same
decision every time.
Cool. Um and so, if we can if you
actually want to think about maximizing
rewards,
we can then
add in the policy into this diagram
where there's essentially if you if you
have access to state, there would be an
arrow from here to here that is modeling
this distribution. And likewise, from
here to here.
Now, if we then want to actually write
down
what rewards look like,
we need to think about a probability
distribution over trajectories.
You actually need to think about like
what is
um
yeah, what is actually the kind of
distribution over
um over futures that we'll see.
The way that we can think about that is
we'll have
some initial state. Uh there may
actually also be randomness here that we
haven't talked about. Like the initial
conditions of the world might change.
And if you're like playing a game, for
example, like how all the cards are
dealt out will vary.
And then after the state, there is
um you're going to be making a decision
with your policy.
And then once you make that decision,
there is randomness that arises from
the
um from the dynamics.
And then we if we want to think about
the probability of a given trajectory,
it's going to be the probability of the
first state, then the probability of
taking the next action, then the
probability of taking the next uh
observing the next state, then the
probability of taking the action after
that, and then the next state, and so
on. And so then we can think about
the probability
of a given trajectory as being
the initial state probability plus the
product of the probabilities from the
policy and the dynamics.
Where uh here it's equal to 1 to
capital T.
And then once we formulate this
probability distribution over
trajectories,
then we can think about maximizing
reward as actually maximizing our
expected rewards under this probability
distribution.
So,
we'll kind of think about the
expectation of trajectories sampled from
this distribution
of
the sum
like state and actions in this
trajectory
of
the reward of that state and action.
Um and then this is our goal our goal is
to maximize this and our goal is to find
a policy pi
that maximizes these expected sum of
rewards.
And so that is
written
right here.
Now note that unlike in supervised
learning
we
um this doesn't look like something that
you can like
very like
well pi actually doesn't even appear in
this equation but the way that it comes
in is how it's affecting the
trajectories.
So this distribution of trajectories is
a function of pi right here.
And
you actually want to find the the the
the policy that will lead to the highest
reward.
Uh and a lot of this class will be
figuring out how do we actually optimize
behavior um
under this particular objective.
Yeah the question is does capital T have
to be fixed? Uh it does not have to be
fixed. It can be variable. Um it's a
little bit easier to write down if it's
fixed uh but
um yeah you can also think about it as
like
um like basically the the length of the
trajectory.
Yeah so one other topic that will come
up in depth a lot more is um
when you think about rewards this is
waiting the rewards over the entire
trajectory equally and it's saying that
you care about immediate reward just as
much as you care about future rewards.
And
in some cases you might care about
immediate reward more than future reward
reward. So for example, if this T is
like a 1,000 years,
maybe you don't care so much about your
rewards 1,000 years from now than you
care about your rewards today.
Uh and so another way that you can
actually formulate the reinforcement
learning objective is not just this kind
of vanilla sum of rewards, but you can
actually wait your rewards by what's
called a discount factor, where that
discount factor actually depends on T.
So, you actually
uh one of the ways we often do that is
adding a discount factor that's raised
to the power of T.
Um
and this means that if a discount
factor, usually this is some value
that's kind of uh
greater than zero and less than or equal
to one. If this is one, it's the same as
the original formulation.
Um
and as you make it lower and lower,
you're being more greedy. You're caring
a lot more about uh near-term rewards
than about far rewards.
Um yeah, we'll talk a little bit more
about discount factors in uh in a couple
of lectures.
Cool. Um as an aside, uh we've talked
about how
our policy is a distribution and so it's
it's not deterministic, it's stochastic.
Why might we want to do that?
There's a couple of reasons why we might
want our policy to not be deterministic.
The first is that
um
if you want to learn, you probably have
to try different things. Like if you're
learning how to play tennis,
you probably shouldn't try the same
exact technique over and over again. You
need actually explore and uh and and try
different strategies in order to do it.
And so,
that can be represented as a stochastic
policy that's trying a few different
strategies and trying to figure out
which strategy is best.
Um and then another case is there's
scenarios where you collect data from
people uh or from different systems and
those people are taking different
strategies. And if you want to model the
way that they're approaching a problem,
you may need your policies to be
stochastic as well.
Okay. Um, and for this we can also
leverage tool from generative models
where you're actually thinking about,
um, not just a neural network that map
from A to B, but actually a generative
model over actions given states and
observations.
I think this is the last thing we'll
touch touch on and introduce, which is
how do we decide how good, oh well,
okay, second to last thing. Um, how do
we decide how good a policy is?
Uh, and this is really useful to think
about because if you don't know how good
your policy is, then you're not going to
be able to make your policy better.
And the terminology that we use to think
about this is referred to as a value
function.
So, we often think about the value
function for a policy of a given state,
and we denote it, uh, typically as V pi
of S.
And essentially what this means is it's
the
future expected reward if you start at S
and then follow pi from then onward.
Um, and so it's basically this equation
except starting at S under, um,
under your current policy.
Um, the And similarly to this, another,
um, thing that we'll start talking about
not in Friday's lecture, but starting
next week is Q value functions as well.
And this is very similar to the value
function, but instead of starting at S,
you're you're actually starting from S,
then taking action A, and then following
pi. Where action A might be different
from what policy pi might have taken.
I'm not going to go into depth on what
these two functions are today, but I
wanted to introduce them because we'll
be using them quite a lot. Um, and so
it's good to start wrapping your head
around what they are,
uh, uh, and as we start to use them more
in future lectures.
Okay, and then the types of algorithms
we'll cover,
uh, the idea behind imitation learning
is to mimic a policy that achieves high
reward.
We'll then next week start talking about
policy gradients that try to directly
differentiate this objective and
actually learn from from practice and
experience.
From there, we'll talk about
actor-critic algorithms that estimate
the value of the current policy and use
it that to make the policy better.
We'll talk about value-based methods
that try to estimate the value of the
optimal policy and then use that to back
out a good policy.
And then lastly, we'll talk about
model-based methods that actually learn
how to model the dynamics of the world,
like try to predict the future and then
use that to improve the policy or for
planning.
Now, you might be wondering, why do we
have so many different algorithms for
optimizing this objective? In supervised
learning, we like just have gradient
descent, it works, it's great, it's
simple. Um, in reinforcement learning,
things are less simple.
Algorithms make different trade-offs and
thrive under different assumptions.
Uh, and so, it's going to depend on, for
example, how easy or cheap is it to
collect data. And if you're in a
simulator, for example, it's really,
really cheap to collect lots of data
versus if you're handwriting,
um, kind of
kind of responses or handwriting,
um,
like actually interacting with a person
that's writing things, that's going to
be more expensive.
Um, also, how cheap and and easy are
different forms of supervision? Do you
have demonstrations? Do you have
detailed rewards?
Um, how important is stability and ease
of use versus data efficiency? Uh, maybe
you have more time to, uh, to kind of
change some of the hyper-parameters if
it doesn't need massive amounts of data.
Um, there's also some considerations
with regard to what your actions look
like. How high-dimensional are they? Are
they continuous or discrete?
Uh, is it easy to learn the dynamic
model.
So yeah, these are these are some of the
reasons why we have a lot of different
algorithms and we'll be talking about
different algorithms and where they're
applied in the later parts of this
course.
Okay, so to recap, there's a lot of
terminology and a lot of notation in
reinforcement learning and
we want to start introducing them today
because we'll be starting to use them
quite a bit in the following lectures.
So we talked about states, we talked
about observations, we talked about
actions, reward functions, and also
initial state distribution and dynamics.
These form what's called a Markov
decision process.
Or if you only have observations, it's
called a partially observed Markov
decision process or an MDP or a POMDP. I
didn't want to bring in this notation
until the very end because it
doesn't actually really matter what it's
called, but it's useful in the long term
if people are referring to MDPs, now you
know what they're referring to. They're
referring to this formulation of a
reinforcement learning problem.
And we also talked about trajectories,
policies, the objective of reinforcement
learning, value functions, and and Q
functions for each state.